hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his article the ethical significance
of cost benefit analysis for business
and the professions Robert Audi
considers the role that cost benefit
analysis could play in various ethical
approaches or systems moral theories
essentially and he considers
utilitarianism
conscientological ethics and then virtue
ethics and he concludes by approaching a
point of view which is indeed his own
one that he identifies with and
sometimes we call this intuitionist
ethics following WD Ross's classic
formulation of this which Audi brings up
in this piece but Audi himself prefers
to call this pluralistic ethics and why
does he call it pluralistic ethics
because it's going to take into account
a plurality of principles as we'll we'll
get to
so he's looking to see what role cost
benefit analysis could play Within this
and interestingly it's going to appear
that perhaps it's a little bit less than
with the other rival moral theories if
we're thinking about virtue ethics and
conscient ethics and then certainly less
than utilitarianism which is you know
sort of like cost benefit analysis writ
large
so what is pluralistic ethics he tells
us uh what he
um views this as being it incorporates
virtue ethics conscionism and
utilitarianism how so it incorporates
the utilitarian emphasis on happiness
and suffering the suffering of ourselves
and others the conscient emphasis on
respect for persons which Audi thinks is
really important and The Virtue
theoretic emphasis on the moral
importance of character but then he goes
on and he says it's not a virtue
theoretic view or a master principle
Theory as we could say that conscionism
is maybe utilitarianism if we want to
count the greatest happiness principle
so what does it use for its plurality of
principles
which collectively account for the moral
obligations any plausible ethical Theory
seeks to explain he says there is a
possibly open-ended list of basic Prima
fascia duties that are knowable apart
from Reliance on a comprehensive moral
theory and he says you know I have in
mind what we find in W.D Ross is the
right and the good a classic work in
ethics who posited duties and here he
brings up the ones that that Ross
himself identifies Fidelity and veracity
beneficence and gratitude
self-improvements Justice non-injury and
reparation and he says each of these
represents a source of assignments of
moral values whether or not we use
cost-benefit analysis and arriving at a
decision so what does that mean well
each of these whatever you want to call
them principles values Prima fascia
duties
indeterminate situations it gives us an
idea of what we ought to be looking for
and what we ought to be doing not doing
how we ought to be doing it and gives us
a sense of value here right so in some
situations perhaps non-harming
non-maleficence takes priority in others
perhaps Fidelity does right in others
perhaps Justice is going to and you know
we don't have to go deep into the Weeds
about how this works he says I want to
consider how a cost-benefit analysis
applies in this ethical approach
so he talks then about hard cases
conflicts of moral obligations are
common and present the most difficult
challenges to normative ethics and he
says there's no easy way to settle these
but this is actually How We Do ethics in
large part we don't you know you don't
really have to do an awful lot if it's
easy cases right maybe just educate
people but what if there's genuine
conflicts between what we
sense our moral obligations to be so he
gives you some examples of this
one might have conflicting obligations
under contract to one's employer and
duties of citizenship to the people so
how do you reconcile these take Tire
safety he says how safe must we be in
setting manufacturing standards how
serious is it if tires will not always
withstand illegal speeds that we know
that some people will take them to but
are otherwise safe right and then he
says we could also apply this to
advertising decisions for example
advertising tobacco products in ways
that will tempt those two young to
purchase them legally right and so he
goes on and he he's giving you other
examples what are we really interested
in here so he's going to introduce a
distinction
um that
we have to unpack you could say and he
says that the pluralistic perspective is
actually going to show us some of the
limitations of cost benefit analysis in
ways that of course utilitarianism can't
and virtue ethics and deontological
ethics didn't so he's going to talk
about
organic versus additive
value in terms of intrinsic value
including moral value right so he says
suppose we assign in an intuitive way
positive and negative values to act
types and outcomes taken as morally
relevant by W.D Ross's framework so we
got these Prima fascia duties we get
into a situation we're like okay which
duties apply how do we assign values to
them how is this going to work
he says this can be an issue when
Justice Fair distributions and
beneficence doing good to other people
are in a kind of opposition now here he
actually has a very interesting case
right he says consider a man who is a
malicious criminal and unrepentantly
serving his sentence our duty of
beneficence would suggest a positive
valuation on providing him with
Pleasures such as cable television
by the way this is the case in many
American prisons right you can purchase
a television set of course you pay a lot
of money more than you would out on the
normal economy for that and then you can
have it in your cell and you can watch
uh whatever cable the prison itself
subscribes to right so this is a actual
sort of case and beneficence would say
all right give give them that that's
that's nice right uh it's helping him
out but
consider the overall value of the State
of Affairs the unrepentant malicious
criminals enjoying his evenings although
we've added something good in itself the
sort of thing we like to add to the
lives of people who don't have it in so
doing we have created a state of affairs
that is intrinsically worse the
pleasures we would beneficently give ill
befit their unrepentant malicious
recipient right so we're creating
Injustice we're contravening the uh
value or principle of Justice in this
case by doing beneficence so we have a
real conflict of Duties now Audi doesn't
actually go further with this analysis
as somebody who's actually taught in a
Maximum Security Prison where prisoners
did in fact get to watch TV I can tell
you that there's other uh Prima fascia
duties that could apply in this case for
example
um that of non-maleficence are not
harming because because
guards and you know administrators they
love for prisoners to have TVs you know
why not out of the kindness of their
heart not because they're doing
beneficence they love for prisoners to
have TVs for two main reasons one is if
you're in your cell watching TV you're
not out of yourself doing something
you're not supposed to be doing either
to the guards or to your fellow
prisoners right so it tends to curb
violence to some degree and
it also gives the administration one
more thing they can hold over the
prisoner to ensure compliance to ensure
good behavior if you're bad we're going
to take your TV away from you right so
the situation if we actually know much
about this and this is why it's
important to like actually think
empirically about these matters it might
involve several different interesting
conflicts going on which might make us
say well we're not happy with the
Injustice of this malicious person
enjoying cable television but on the
other hand keeps them busy and that's
good for making sure he doesn't affect
anybody else right so he goes on and he
says um
it would be unjust to give him
television and if so if that is it's
because of a relation among the elements
and the overall State of Affairs that is
what he means by organic additive means
you can just add the numbers to each
other
um with this organic means there's a
complex thing here he says Injustice is
not an element like pain consequential
upon non-normative states of Affairs
meaning like you poke somebody in the
eye that's going to hurt right that's a
non-normative state of affairs but the
pain itself is is uh something that uh
we we sense it is consequential upon the
unfittingness of the good treatment of
the criminal to his evil disposition his
unmitigated malice right so we're not
just adding things up and he says this
doesn't preclude our assigning of value
to the overall State of Affairs but it
does imply that initial assignments of
value are at best
guidelines and he's he actually suggests
that maybe we have to fine-tune these
over time in what he calls reflective
equilibrium which is a term that's
coming from a different philosopher
um you know it's a matter of sort of
like recalibrating rethinking things
over time
um it's John Rawls who who if I remember
right first coins that that phrase which
then gets used by a lot of ethicists
later on so
he goes on and he says that what if we
take a different example consider a case
in which we're deciding what fine to
levy on a business found guilty of
breaking the rules of bid rigging
imagine that I'm the judge and I have
legal discretion if I think that the
fine money would on my recommendation be
put to a good purpose like funding
research and ethics that might send a
message I'm biased by my own interests
it might also reduce disincentives for
similar offenses where I stand to be the
judge in the case and my favorite causes
coincide with that of the offender now
the Assumption there that Audi hasn't
spelled out is that the fine money the
money that would be spent on the fine
would be spent by the corporation doing
ethics research which I'm in favor of
and so he says imagine I'm able to
assign numbers to represent values and
probabilities I may add the value of the
outcomes and find it quite positive in
comparing the two judgment options I may
decide the higher number doesn't
represent My overall assessment of
preferability right and so I I can
recalculate or bring about reflective
equilibrium and he goes on uh from this
and he's going to talk about the role
that intuition has to play now he
doesn't mean intuition just as like
pulling stuff out of the air he means
our developed moral intuitions about
things which can be better or worse and
that's part of this pluralistic ethics
approach he says that the cost benefit
analysis allows an intuitive assignment
of values to outcomes that are not
analyzed into components right and we
rely on our intuitions to do that now we
could also rely on the intuitions of
other people our intuitions can be
Better or Worse developed and so he says
cost benefit analysis is not
inapplicable
but what we have to do is use intuition
at what he calls a global level in
evaluating the elements within a whole
such as an action with multiple
consequences so by giving cable
television to the malicious unrepentant
murderer that's going to produce a worse
State of Affairs overall that that I can
arrive at a morally satisfactory value
for that option right so he says that um
some people might find this appeal to
intuition Troublesome
but I think that as good as we can
actually get I have to look to the
overall character of an act in relation
to the situation and
I almost said Ross Audi who is a
follower of Ross in this respect thinks
that this is probably as good as it's
going to get so we can use cost-benefit
analysis with pluralistic ethics it
takes some working out of things and the
best that we can arrive at are sort of
rough estimates
which is the case anyway for pluralistic
ethics there aren't any rules that
govern everything all the time we have
to exercise some some judgment some as
we say Common Sense we have to exercise
our intuitions in applying these various
Prima fascia duties or moral principles
but there is some scope for cost-benefit
analysis to be useful in this